as you know uh the two top stories in
the nfl
are aaron rodgers is not shown for work
at a mandatory mini camp
in green bay we talked about that with
albert breer and with a bunch of phone
callers earlier today and the other one
is the fact that julio jones is no
longer in atlanta he's now
tennessee titan and somebody who thought
about this a long time ago
somebody who i think spoke it into
existence or
tick-tocked it into existence or tweeted
it into existence
is on the phone line right now the pride
of starkville
mississippi who has been balling out in
his first two years
as a professional wide receiver and now
gets to call
julio jones a teammate aj brown of the
tennessee titans kind enough to call
into the rich eisen show right now how
are you aj brown
i'm good how are you doing i'm doing
fine so you spoke this into existence is
that a proper way to to
to determine aj what do you think i
guess you could say that i kind of
manifested
manifested it you know so uh i put it in
the air you did
yes you put it in the air to say the
least so
um how how i mean
what's it like now to have him as your
teammate after putting it in the air and
and saying this should happen aj
um it's great to be honest um
man julio were already like cool and um
so now i don't have to call and ask them
about football now i can see it
firsthand in practice you know i can ask
some questions and practices and
and i can learn i can learn in a faster
way so
this is huge for me huge for the team
you know
so so when you say uh ask him
about stuff you were doing that over the
last two years
of course most definitely most
definitely you know uh
i studied this game because um
we're bigger receivers and and uh he's
done it the right way
and he runs routes like a smaller guy so
that's that's what i'm chasing that's
what i'm trying to trying to accomplish
each and every day yeah
and just asking him all over the phone
it's no longer now i can just actually
practice well how'd you first get hooked
up with how did you get first get hooked
up with julio jones
aj um through our agency um
through our agency and uh i think the
first time i met him i was in la
and he was just talking to me giving me
advice before i even took the field as a
rookie
so um he was he always been
a mentor for me so so
um what does he what a can you give me
an example of what he has
given you some advice on that you were
able to translate into the field with
two
thousand yard receiving seasons 19
touchdowns under your belt already and
just
the first two years in the nfl it's a
collective thing it's a collective
thing a lot of things to be honest um
just just my game overall
you know um like i said like i'm trying
to make my game
as similar to his game you know since
i'm a bigger receiver
similar style similar height some of the
way so i'm just trying to
i'm just trying to uh match him as much
as i can
okay and so uh who come who who's your
uh producer on your tick tock and your
videos and things of that nature
aj i'm the producer starring me
published by me
everything you're you're one-man band
you're coming up with your rhymes
really okay all right
um where'd you get the tape for uh to
tape over
the jersey where'd you get the blue tape
from aj i got it from home depot i was
uh
paying my my daughter's room uh uh like
a month ago and i had some tape left
over
so like you're gonna get some of that
tape you had left over and
and then you put eight there because
that's his alabama number is that why
you chose eight
yeah that's alabama now okay that's
where you chose eight and then you're
the one who wrote titans on the tape and
put it over the falcons part of the
jersey
you did that yeah yeah i felt like that
was that was funny
well you don't have to feel that it was
hilarious i mean it's just
it's not just funny it was absolutely
hilarious and we were all thinking could
this possibly happen and now
now it has so we also saw
your tweet uh that you asked us to
excuse your language that
you say you all done f this up um
and i think i've quoted you properly
what do you mean by that
when everybody's f this up aj brown what
do you mean
um um to be honest
um like in practice they called me they
was calling me baby julio so now you got
julio
and a guy who's trying to be like julio
on the same team i think i think the
the sky's the limit so i don't think
they can call me baby
no more so well i mean you're right
there and then there's uh the grown-ass
man that wears 22
as well um what
what what you know my god um what's the
weight room going to be like
with everybody there now um to be honest
like everybody doesn't know like um
derek controls the weight room he
controls the music he controls
everything
like it's really his show in the weight
room like
i don't even try to compete with him we
hope we just go we do our thing
we just let derrick do his thing he'd be
pumping pumping
weight yelling and everything he kind of
like i said one band show
in the weight room okay so maybe that's
where you picked up your social media
game from there but
um what do you mean that he controls
everything in the weight room
what do you mean by that because he he
derek
missed the house he like he missed he
loses so much weight
he controls the music he controls how
loud the music is like
he's in there screaming pumping like
he's he fires up he loves the weight
room he loves the way
he's probably working out right now well
julio is a more tenured crimson tide um
he might not be more tenured on
tennessee so
does julio get any privileges of of the
music and anything like that
or what yeah yeah yeah yeah but
i mean how did god get a privilege of of
the like the music and stuff but okay
but derek just being there
just doing it too much in a way wrong
and we just let him do his thing
when he done we could we control the
music we turn to music
and his thing is do you do the um metal
chain uh around the neck uh push-ups on
the
resistance band and toes on the ball do
you do that too
aj brown no i know i didn't do that i
never tried to do that
uh like like i said derek just does
stuff
uh he come up with ideas to try to lift
weights that's how you know he loves the
weight room because
you can just do some regular push-ups
[Laughter]
you could yeah i guess you gotta stand
on a ball
one leg like that's so dangerous like
let's just let's just do regular
push-ups like we will get the same thing
out of it
i guess you could but if he could do the
other one you do that
i'm gonna i'm gonna put you on the spot
aj brown um okay
who's who who could who could rule the
weight room more
in terms of doing cr you know wild
things that you don't think a human
being can do
derek henry or dk metcalf aj
[Music]
oh bk bk is a monster in the weight room
too
i think i got to go with derek though i
got to go with derek well i mean he's
your current teammate i think that's the
smart answer you're a smart man
you don't share the weight room with dk
what the hell was it like
on an sec saturday with you and dk
metcalf strolling on the field you must
have felt like kings of the world
together like that yeah was it was
absolutely fine it was absolutely fun
everybody was kind of scared of us
um other than like alabama
they weren't scared of you that everyone
else was they weren't they weren't too
scared i love that
that is so funny but and it's amazing
what he's become too what the two of you
have done
in the first two years of your career
how much uh do you guys talk to one
another
we talk to each other uh often you know
uh he's he's busy right now we talking
it's all mutual we know we got a lot of
respect for each other
we chasing the same goal so um we stay
in contract though
okay does that also include uh running a
hundred meters
and stuff like that or no you can do
that uh we thought we talked about that
a little bit
uh you know i i cannot do that but i was
all for
i was all for cheering him on and you
know him doing that and him
him doing that stuff that was pretty
impressive few more minutes left with aj
brown here on the rich eisen show
okay we also noticed your your tweet
today as well
uh about the number that you currently
wear
and did you offer 11 to julio jones and
he said no
aj yeah i most definitely i most
definitely sat down to talk to him about
it and
i tried to give my number up to him and
uh he refused to take it so
why what can you give me a little bit
more
uh of that i can't go into i can't go
into detail unless he tells unless he
tells everyone that
okay um but i think
he just he just refused to take it and
you know i was you know definitely i was
okay with that
yeah i'm sure what's that gonna mean to
you as somebody who looked up to him
and mo have molded your game um
off of his and emulate the way that he
plays and have picked his brain
that he said you keep that number i'll
choose a different
one what does that mean to you um
it means a lot to me because it tells me
that i'm headed in the right direction
you know um i'm doing everything i'm
supposed to be doing so far
i just got to keep working and and keep
growing um but for for a guy like them
just to
show me the respect you know it means a
lot to me so
um yeah that is amazing what if i told
you you'd be teammates with him
one day like literally when you're
coming off the campus
in in mississippi and yeah and and hey
you're going to be a teammate of his in
just a couple years as a matter of fact
no clue
i i i wouldn't believe you i wouldn't
believe you at all
i'm just so happy for you and obviously
everybody there um and
you know uh and i appreciate you calling
in i'm i'm gonna do my best
aj to make your world better
and your social media game better
and that's the big setup for this okay
i have uh a long history of attempting
to
give nicknames to players uh in the nfl
and i'll be
very honest with you it's a checkered
past um
not many have accepted my offers but i
kind of dig this
one and i will let you know i'll let you
know it is
it is recycled aj because it was just a
few short weeks ago
that i uh had matt ryan on and with him
and kyle pitts and calvin ridley
and julio jones i said we should call
you for
the pitstastic four and i made up the
photograph of all four of them on the
heads of the famed fantastic four comic
book guys
well that's obviously no longer
operative
so now i have come up with this version
of it called the
ten-tastic for t-e-n-n short for
tennessee
right and you are the uh elastic man
because you're the one who can get in
the end zone
you can stretch defenses okay okay uh
tannehill is the man in the middle he's
uh
he's the man in the middle with the uh
invisibility
because he can just disappear and just
reappear and
make things happen in that regard
obviously the thing
is the man who's in charge of the weight
room derrick henry exactly
exactly and and then you've got um
julio's the human torch because he can
burn dbs all day long
and you're the one who can stretch d's
and mastermind blockbuster trades
what do you think of this aj brown i
like it i like the fantastic four
i like it now hold on a second now you
do realize
that this is this is a big moment for me
and you know i know we're just
getting to know one another this is big
are you just saying that
or do you really no no no no most
definitely no i i like it i like it a
lot
okay can i can i have this sent to you
and then you may have all the rights to
use it however you wish
and make it as aj brown instagram
tick tock twitter famous as you'd like
most definitely most definitely i use it
oh my gosh
you have no idea wow you aj you have you
have
made this dude's year he is so happy
right now
yeah i i definitely use it without a
doubt okay
because i think this is pretty
ten-tastic of all of you guys to do this
and it's ten-tastic of you to say yes
i'm pushing it too far right now
okay just slow down take the win he said
he liked it
he said he's gonna run with it accept
that and let's you know
all right nicely in the interview aj
thank you for everything
thank you thank y'all let's do this more
often let's do this oh by the way what's
your daughter's name you said
you're you're you're painting her room
my daughter's name is jersey
jersey okay jersey a very and how old is
she
oh she's one years old oh man soak it in
aj brown enjoy it look at this
you got a one-year-old at home and
you've got uh two ones on your chest
because julio jones says keep it
how's that i love it
congrats thank you you got it all right
aj
look out for this uh this uh this meme
it's coming your way thanks for the call
thank you you got there you go there's
aj brown tennessee titans
wow the ten tastic four the ten has been
accepted
what a win and as you know when you
throw something to aj brown it will be
received he's gonna catch his comments
catching it
dude how happy are you right now
i think i'm gonna win the emmy tonight
this is my day
if you win the emmy tonight only thank
aj brown
like just get up there or get on the
zoom oh yeah all my colleagues
it doesn't matter thank you aj brown
those guys no don't thank us don't thank
susie
oh thank aj brown for accepting the
tentastic four like i'm accepting this
award that's not actually in my hands
because this is all virtual
that would be amazing all right so i'm
just going to
tweet this picture out to him right now
and then i mean
hopefully he sees it and runs the answer
is
go forth sir did we get the updated one
yeah okay
yeah we put it up tentastic four it's
all been workshopped and
approved they all have to accept it
though in reality
why wouldn't anybody else accept this
even if aj gives his stamp like let's go
he's the one
he's the one if i look it's kind of like
with my children
if i suggest something they'll say no
but if somebody else suggests something
that's
appear yes absolutely right if i say hey
uh ryan how do you like the ten-tastic
four i might get the matt ryan response
well you know i don't know
but it's aj brown the calls are coming
from within the house
fantastic
it's like you're in the grocery line the
bags are they're you're now just getting
out of the store just get it done
just know when to leave fantastic hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here